bonjour bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition deux points de vue 48 ni de
débat sur la politique le sport et l'art
et pas n'importe quel art puisqu'il
s'agit de léonard de vinci sport et
politique ça peut faire bon ménage en
tout cas ça semble être un ticket
gagnant pour emmanuel macron battre le
pavé c'est aussi du sport mais les
syndicats sont relégués aujourd'hui dans
les profondeurs du classement
quant à la diplomatie ça peut être aussi
du sport la france marque-t-elle un
point en accueillant saad hariri
on va en parler merci à tous d'être si
nombreux à nous suivre et bonjour à tous
les quatre bonjour emmanuel rivière
vous êtes directeur de l'institut kantar
public et vous enseigner la
communication politique bonjour un enfer
pour jour olivier duhamel large aux
juristes politologues vous êtes aussi
l'animateur de l'émission médiapolis le
samedi matin sur europe 1 où vous
décrypter avec délice le jeu
politico-médiatique et vous est
également l'auteur de macron et en même
temps qui est paru chez plon en 2010 est
coauteur avec laurent bigot et alice
beaudry bonjour paul quinio vous êtes
rédacteur en chef à l'ops loeb ce qui
fait sa couverture cette semaine sur le
peuple de macron avec ce sous titre qui
sont les marcheurs du président ces
marcheurs qui se cherche encore à la
veille de leur congrès fondateur à lyon
ce week-end on va en parler
on en a aussi parlé dans le figaro n'est
ce pas l'ex il explose et directeur des
rédactions du figaro
alors effectivement s noël avant l'heure
la coupe du monde de rugby en france la
vente record d'airbus a320 les jo de
2024 à paris et même en foot on ne perd
plus contre l'allemagne il y a comme un
petit parfum d'euphorie certes emmanuel
macron n'est pas le père noël il ne
guérit pas non plus des écrouelles mais
il a du talent pour récolter ce qu'il
n'a pas semé avant d'en parler je vous
pose une question à tous les quatre
rapide qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
un an c'était le 16 novembre 2016 pile
poil ya un an
crowcon la avons bien vu on va l'écouter
quand nos par le violent soufflant suis
candidat à la présidence de la
république
parce que je crois plus que tout que
nous pouvons réussir que la france peut
réussir
bien sûr on ne se réveille pas un matin
avec cette révélation la décision de me
présenter aux plus hautes charges de la
république est le fruit d'une conviction
intime et profonde d'un sens de
l'histoire et d'une conscience aiguë des
temps qui sont les nôtres
alors c'est tout à bobigny dans un
centre d'apprentissage il avait pas tout
à fait la même assurance le même ton
emmanuel macron sur la forme les
visionner d'abord il faut bien voir que
à l'époque la plupart des commentateurs
a été assez sceptique y compris le soir
et le lendemain de cette déclaration de
candidature qui était on va dire assez
empruntés dans ce convoi
même dans l'extrait convient d'entendre
c'est que déjà la modestie n'était quand
même pas son force à sa conscience aigüe
etc
mais je pense que l'une des raisons de
l'explication en dehors de la gravité du
moment c'est que il sent bien qu'il ya
un vrai doute ce qui va s qui va avoir
le momentum ou pas il n'est pas du tout
convaincu il est convaincu que ce qui
est très fort chez lui s'il était
convaincu très très tôt qui avait un
trou d'aiguillé et qui savaient pas
s'ils arriveraient à passer dedans mais
que true existerait et que ça valait le
coup de tenter sa chance à ça et c'est
cette amérique qui l'a de l'avs aperçu
très tôt mais bon après ça a mis du
temps
moi je tiens qu'il n'avait pas prévu
qu'on pouvait pas le prévoir
l'effondrement du candidat de la droite
qu'à l'époque on connaissait d'ailleurs
pas au revoir je pense que sont son
intuition c'est à dire si j'y vais
hollande n'ira pas hollande ne peut pas
gagner si c'est ça je pense que deux des
bus il ça il le sait et c'est un vrai
risque parce que partir quand on est
ministre pour quasi inconnu contre le
président de la république ça s'est
jamais vu qu'un président réplique sur
présente qui peut se représenter
et ça il le sent il a vécu le truc de
l'intérieur il se dit ne pourra pas mais
mais mais il se dit ne pourra pas y
aller
et à l'époque peu sont 100 kg qui dit je
pense à un pari risqué appareils ce qui
effectivement l'entourage emmanuel
macron au moment où il fait cette
déclaration de candidature beaucoup de
gens se demandent si ce pari est
gagnable peut-être que l'intéressé
lui-même d'ailleurs n'est pas sûr de sa
réussite
mais dans le même moment les français
sont intéressés par emmanuel macron ce
qui était très surprenant dans les
sondages on avait fait le figaro dès la
rentrée dès la rentrée c'est de voir que
le capital de popularité quitté quitté
fort de manuel macron se transformer en
capital électoral ça arrive une fois sur
10 a qu'une personnalité populaire
transforme 15% 16% selon les hypothèses
est systématiquement au-dessus de
françois hollande pour ça qu
effectivement le moment était très
important parce que c'est l'acte qui a
entraîné la décision trois semaines plus
tard si mes souvenirs sont bons de
françois hollande de considérer que les
réelles conditions pour une somme de 10
ans l'ops
vous aviez vu que l'essai pouvait se
transformer oui on avait on avait été
les premiers effectivement a souligné
comment mme emmanuelle mâcon se préparer
et c'est ça qui est aussi important dans
sa déclaration c'est que même si le ton
n'est pas assurée vous avez raison je
pense qu'il a déjà à ce moment là un
plan très précis de sa campagne et que
c'est d'une certaine manière ça qui lui
va lui permettre de gagner à l'arrivée
l'équipe
il sait où il va quand même une certaine
manière dès ce moment là alors j'ai
repris quelques déclarations c'est vrai
le jour même des politiques de réaction
il ya alain juppé qui dit il y avait
déjà françois hollande qui l'a
poignardée dans le dos et maintenant ce
jeu qui ne m'intéresse pas mais est il à
ce moment là manuel valls rien ne
m'affecte réagissait-il pour gouverner
il faut une expérience qui a été
éprouvée par le temps il disait refuser
les aventures individuelles le marine le
pen disait même pas peur 20 les
commentaires politiques les relire le
plus passionnant ses valses trouve pas
ce qu'il ya vous pouvez relire la phrase
rien ne m'affecte et de vernis il est
très affecté pour gouverner il faut une
expérience qu'elle fonctionne et parle
de l'expérience et de l'épreuve il de
l'expérience il faut viser les aventures
individuelles
ils sont ravis d'avoir enfin il avait
donc tout est faux dans les trois
phrases c'est vraiment absolument
fascinant comment un type aussi
intelligent valcy aucun doute le type
est tout sauf idiots ne comprend rien au
moment politique les t3 et trois parties
latérales sont franchement ce que lui
qui la lui il a compris que ça
débouchait son espace à lui alors qu'à
la même époque juppé et je pense qu'il
pense franchement que c'est que c'est
pas dangereux que ça va juste en bon
passionné hollande mais que c'est quand
même que c'est pas vraiment le problème
est donc du coup il tape il tape temps
qui peut je pense que vaslui c'est que
c'est cuit pour lui les autres les
autres îles de sa forme presque juppé il
faut bien là ils pensent jurés les
femmes
oui ils pensent que c'est un bayrou bis
alors que l'euro va être avec lui du
pays et donc qu'il pense que je pense
qu'au fond l'humain il pense que ma
convainc termine à 5 ou un truc comme ça
vous dit pas loin
10 % sera une épine dans le pied
hollande et il fallut gênant pour lui
non pas évident pour lui est ce qui est
assez plaisant à voir aussi c'est tout
les commentaires c'est at il une stature
internationale il est inconnu va très
vite ça laisse à part l'a dit c'est que
dans l'analyse politique et c'est normal
parce que sinon sur quoi on s'appuie on
attend toujours à reproduire le passé
c'est d'ailleurs c'est quand même une
des règles enfin pour essayer d'analyser
les choses ont des bacs comment
jusqu'ici ça s'est fait jusqu'ici un
type qui est qu'on connaissait pas qui a
pas de parti qui n'existe que depuis dix
ans ça marche pas et c'est logique enfin
c'est assez rationnel comme façon j
et puis il ya des voies faire ça neuf
fois sur dix il faut aussi à chaque fois
qu'on fait ça il faut le faire il faut
quand même le faire plus que le font la
plupart des journalistes politiques qui
s'intéressent pas assez à l'histoire
même la plus récente mais en même temps
une fois qu'on a qu'on a fait ce travail
avec il faut se mettre à côté et 10
rebonds mais maintenant s'il y avait du
neuf
parce que si on se pose pas cette
question rate élections club et en rack
le phénomène macron et c'est ça qui est
difficile c'est qu'il faut l'aimer deux
démarches
alors on revient à la période présente
on a fait un sondage au doxa le figaro à
paraître demain
il apparaît juste un truc intéressant
c'est que dans les personnalités qui
sont souhaitées états qui sont estimés
comme un atout pour le gouvernement s'il
y avait un remaniement c'est alain juppé
qui bat tous les records à 63 % voient
s'afficher c'est surtout le seul qui
sont un atout c'est comme ça qui me
frappe parce que lui ont dicté en a tous
53 % contre 46 c'est pas énorme mais
après tout les autres qu'on a testé
borloo bertrand delanoë pécresse royal
estrosi val seine conneries aucun n'est
considéré comme un atout pour le
gouvernement compte sans doute parce que
les gens de gauche ont pas envie que de
voir les gens de droite arrivé les gens
droite ont pas envie de voir les gens de
gauche arrivés l'un dans l'autre ils
sont pas considérés comme des atouts
dans l'eau quand même bon évidemment ces
îles et ses minorités mais on aurait pu
imaginer qu'une personnalité centrale et
consensuelle comme borloo
oui après tout face 60 % de gens qui
disent bah oui c'est bien pour macron et
surtout que à l'ère du dégagement et
jour après jour
juppé n'est pas dans la maison de
retraite il ya beaucoup de choses qui
relèvent de l'anomalie dans ce qu'on
constate dans les baromètres de
popularité d'un baromètre figaro
magazine alain juppé est de très loin la
première presse personnalité dans les
rangs des républicains aux yeux des
français globalement et des républicains
ce qui n'est tout à fait singulier
compte tenu de la défaite cinglante et
quasi humiliante qu'il ait essuyé lors
de la primaire ok il reste une valeur
sûre qui peut être fait un peu
contrepoids ou contrepoint avec l'image
d'emmanuel macro ans
d'ailleurs quand on voit les
personnalités qui sont ici prise et on
voit bien comment chacun constitue une
sorte d'abord par rapport à peut-être
des cases qui sont imprimés à prendre en
compte c'est vrai qu'il y manque d'une
très forte personnalité d'un
gouvernement juppé il doit franchir le
pas ou pas finalement on dit je fasse du
passeport emmanuel macron l'arrivée du
gp serait forcément une bonne chose
alain juppé il a une bonne image
pourquoi parce qu'il incarne
le vieux sage d'une certaine manière
donc
mais de l'intégrer dans un gouvernement
ça fait quand même retour à l'ancien
monde alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé que veut faire mieux le mac
ont donc je la sais j'en suis pas sûr de
gagner en répondant aussi à votre
question c'est pas non plus l'intérêt
d'alain juppé l'intérêt d'alain juppé
s'est pas de revenir mais et a misé 2 6
ça et ça sont intéressés c'est de
devenir un personnage à l'ats jacques
delors ou enfin un intérêt c'est un
intérêt pour macron c'est que ces
inconnues de mettre le bazar chaude aux
républicains
de ce point de vue là pour lui c'est
plutôt une bonne chose oui mais il peut
y avoir par exemple
oui oui mais enfin ce n'est pas inutile
d'avoir un petit électro et justement
libre à l'ambiguïté à limite ça
s'arrange celle là
non mais je pense que même juppé de vue
sa vie il faut pas se rater je n'ai pas
envie d'être nouveau mini il a peut-être
min sous les ors de voir philippe il se
voit pas en me disant je pense que il ne
s'imagine pas ça en revanche un destin
européen
pourquoi pas ça ça peut l'intéresser et
d'ailleurs quand il commence à parler du
grand corps central fin du grand il dit
pas on dit panini dit pas liste mais
enfin on comprend quand même l'idée de
s'entendre avec les maquereaux nice aux
européennes on se dit qu'il a peut-être
ensuite eu une idée derrière la tête ça
oui c'est possible
il ya un petit paradoxe comme dans la
situation du moment c'est que emmanuel
macron est quand même en train d'essayer
de socialiser son image on a vu son
essai déplacement en banlieue ces
derniers jours il essaye de se détacher
de cette image de président des riches
qui lui colle à la peau depuis quelques
mois le
juppé n'incarne pas ce petit déplacement
sur la gauche qu'il était en train
d'essayer d'opérer ils essayent sur des
sujets qui sont pas trop gênant pour
juppé pas sur des sujets plus lourds
comme le strict régalien etc ni sur
l'économie au sens strict mais sur la
mise donc bon dire qu'on va faire de la
politique de pour les banlieues enfin
c'est ni plus immense que je faisais
borloo veut dire comme au tournant à
gauche c'est pas non plus même alexis
peu suspect zéro un peu plus consensuel
le rugby puisque effectivement c'était
notre point de départ avec cette coupe
du monde qui aura lieu en france
je vous propose on va reparler tout ça
de ses succès alors est-ce que c'est du
talent est ce que c'est de la chance
christophe dominici l'ancien joueur de
rugby qui saluait la performance de
bernard laporte
je crois que bernard laporte mobile
monstrueux pendant cette quinzaine et
notamment pendant les derniers trois
jours c'est incroyable il a réussi à
retourner une situation qui était plutôt
va le remarquer je peux me permettre ce
mec me surprend de plus en plus
honnêtement vous avez tous connus et
plus en plus savourer beaucoup de choses
ici des joueurs sur le terrain avec le
même état d'esprit que lui cet esprit de
compétition et cette soif de gagner
je crois qu'on n'en gagnerait beaucoup
plus de matches sur l'allemand alors
tout ne se vaut pas mais effectivement
le maquereau la chance sur ces sur des
choses qui n'a pas engagé au départ on
dit mais moi je sais bien qu'ici je dois
être le soi-disant le type un peu de
gauche de service que j'ai d'ailleurs je
refuse absolument je ne suis là que pour
mes analyses et quand je vous surprend
tant mieux mais franchement macro n'y
est pour rien dans le dico maillot qu'on
n'y est pour rien dans le rugby
macron il peut rien sur rien alors on
peut dire qu'il a la baraka que quand on
aime bien le surnaturel où napoléon on
dit bon
le général s'il a de la chance et que
macron c'est bien qu'il ai de la chance
mais à part ça c'est pipeau tout ça ça
n'a pas de conséquence la france sur le
jour où je suis pas sûr d'être
complètement d'accord sur le rugby où
ils vous avez raison il est pour rien et
après l'histoire de ces quinze derniers
jours n'est pas écrite encore je sais
pas on sais pas je pense que c'est
vraiment passé dans le rhône à l'endroit
du alors que la caisse sur les géo je
trouve qu'il a quand même voilà il a su
prendre
il a pris le train en marche il a tout
de suite mis son
c'est un gouvernement en branle donc
voilà il n'a pas été décisif mais il a
quand même voilà embrasser le truc assez
vite si on réfléchit qui était le
scénario que les gens qui nous regardent
de l'extérieur c'est à dire les
différents pays étrangers et puis le
comité international olympique avait en
tête au moment des présidentielles
maquereau ou le pen non le scénario de
la lecture de macron était plutôt un
facilitateur que scénario inverse par
rapport à l'obtention des légions
tout ça est importante pour les français
même si le rugby c'est pas le foot
l'accumulation des success important
quand on demandait aux tréfonds de la
défiance et du marasme du moral des
français quels étaient les grands
souvenirs qu'ils avaient de de grandeur
de la france
il se reportait à l'accouplement de 1998
à voir ces grands événements chez soi
ces indicateurs de quelque chose et je
pense que même si effectivement dans
rugby
je suis bien incapable de lire de
décrypter la généalogie de la décision
mais il ya bien quelque chose qui a
changé quand même dans le regard que les
étrangers que dirigeant les responsables
les investisseurs étrangers portent sur
la france sont pas des français il est
pas d'accord c'est bien je trouve c'est
un peu grâce à vous accrocher peut-être
qu'il a raison grâce à mâcon mais que ça
a des conséquences sur le regard qu'on a
sur lui alors ce qui se passe ici macron
améliore le regard sur la france
et si le regard me forcez pas maintenant
à dire le propos est pas content parce
que si le la logique de ce que vient de
dire emmanuel avec bière c'est quand
même que macron il ya une petite part
puisque c'est glee qui changent le
regard sur la france et là changement de
regard sur la france nous aide pour
rugby giot etc
oui oui mais
oui c'est ce que dit emmanuel non ah bah
voilà d'accord sur le rugby moi je me
réfère convaincu quand vous êtes mac
revient vous arrive j'aimerais faire
l'excellent texte et david reyrat ril et
riil explique le truc qui était décisif
il dit que bon c'est manquerons
évidemment pour rien fait c'est l'argent
non c'est la porte et la porte il a
cette idée
ce que n'avait pas eu son prédécesseur
patron de la fédé de dire que les
équipes perdantes resteront à paris
parce que normalement quand on a perdu
on rentre chez soi
et là il dit tout le monde restera tout
le temps du du tournoi et et c'est la
fédération française de rugby qui
prendra en charge des frais d équipe et
ça pour toutes les délégations sur je ne
sais pas combien de votants dans un mais
il y en a 90 % qui savent qu'ils n'ont
aucune chance de gagner qui donc ils
gagnent ce 10 20 nous restera essaie
simplement de rester si j'ai bien que je
m'en sorte de mongla francique de david
reyrat il dit aussi que les retombées
pour la fédération sont plus importantes
parce que c'est la france que si ça
avait été l'afrique du sud pour la
fédération de rugby
ouais ouais il ya aussi un argument
voilà c'est ce que je dirai un argument
financier qui faisait aussi d'argent et
quand
quant à airbus a franchi cc c'est
vraiment séduit
c'était un commercial incroyable entre
airbus et boeing
il se trouve que airbus 5-1 commercial
khider et américains qui est un type
vraiment génial et qui apparemment a mis
tout son poids dans la balance pour
décrocher ce contrat là je crois que
c'est vrai là pour les quarts les
attaques sont pour rien dans cette
histoire
ce contrat inclut la mort avec une
compagnie américaine qui n'est pas une
compagnie aérienne qui est une société
qui voit qu'il va voir d'abord celui là
de niamey dans le grès grand succès
dehors de suez
airbus l'ue la france et les états la
france et en particulier pour beaucoup
vous me voyez venir
c'est bien c'est pas que le libéralisme
pur et dur des doubles donc c'est
important d'avoir un état
mais je ne crois absolument au succès de
l'europe des états aidés
non je ne comportera que soit le
commission de bruxelles qui soit dans
cette affaire d'airbus vous me voyez
venir aux halles commission n'aurait
absolument un autre thème celui de la
loi travail les syndicats sont-ils chaos
on est jeudi pour la quatrième fois
depuis septembre
c'est jour de manif nos jeudi se
ressemblent une mobilisation qui
s'essouffle des syndicats qui
manifestent en ordre dispersé alors ces
syndicats et perd pied sont ils
effectivement définitivement ko la
jonction avec les jeunes est elle un
fiasco on va en parler on écoute jean
luc mélenchon il était ce matin à
marseille
et si on recommence les étapes suivantes
dans les mêmes conditions on peut dire
que le résultat sera le même
il ne faut plus être séparés entre les
syndicats la division syndicale nous a
coûté très cher et puis la séparation du
politique et du syndical tout autant
parce que il ya des milliers des
millions de militants politiques de
personnes engagées qui sont prêtes à
entrer dans l'action mais à condition
qu'on les appelle à une action qui leur
semblent avoir du sens
il fait pas il embarque mélenchon va le
faire croire qu'il ya du monde il
l'avait déjà fait il ya une quinzaine de
jours quand il a considéré que ces macro
qu'a dû marquer le point et de ce
conduit là il a raison quand on voit la
mobilisation d'aujourd'hui qui est
moitié moindre que celle de
enfin que la dernière qui est elle même
étaient déjà un échec les on voit bien
que les syndicats effectivement sont
groggy
ils sont pas forcément définitivement ko
mais ils sont groggy ils sont gros ils
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont divisés
donc il ya la division syndicale qui a
pesé mais surtout ce qui est important
c'est ce qu'a dit mélenchon là dans la
fin de sa phrase c'est son c'est le la
bataille de leadership sur le front
social entre les syndicats et la france
est soumise et qui n'a pas réussi à
créer ce ce pont et à rompre le voilà ce
qu'ont ceux qu'on connaît maintenant
dans paysage syndical depuis des
décennies d'indépendance par rapport aux
partis politiques voilà même les liens
entre la cgt et parti communiste ne sont
plus ce qu'ils étaient et et contreur
c'est peut-être sans doute parce que la
cgt avait trop de liens avec le parti
communiste qui n'ont pas voulu soutenir
mélenchon peut-être les relations comme
elle un jour le bios et humiliations et
aux peines pour mélenchon se prononcer
un discours
parce que dit mélenchon par rapport à la
tradition syndicale française et un
français bien sûr mais un scandale
absolu c'est le syndicalisme français
s'est construit sur la séparation
l'indépendance des critiques mais à tel
point que même quand la cgt en vtt en
vérité un briquet avec le parti
communiste andré semblant être
indépendante et à présent mais que non
et donc quand il dit ça qui a l'air
banal c'est tout sauf banal ça ils
s'assoient sur plus d'un siècle de
tradition syndicale française c'est tout
c'est tout sauf banal et c'est très très
faux puisque sans remettre en cause
même s'ils ont du désir pour la
controverse que dit olivier le problème
des syndicats en france notamment par
rapport à la perception des syndicats en
allemagne avec un décalage de perception
qui est très important c'est que les
français assimile les syndicats aux jeux
politiques et leurs grilles de lecture
de l'action syndicale est vraiment une
transposition des grilles de lecture de
la compétition politique dans
précisément ils ne veulent plus donc le
l'association du syndicat avec l'action
politique était de mon point de vue une
clé d'échec une clé des chèques presse
ça se produit quand même cette
démobilisation dans un moment un peu
curieux parce que il se trouve que
l'image des syndicats s'est plutôt
améliorée depuis
depuis deux ans elle s'est améliorée au
moment des manifestations contre la loi
travail qui ont été plutôt un succès
non couronnées pas de résultats c'était
la fin de ma phrase non couronnée par la
satisfaction de leurs exigences mais un
succès mobilisation est là on a des
objets de mobilisation qui est très
semblable est pas du tout là même le
même succès de d'entraînement parce que
on n'est pas dans le même moment
politique parce qu on est en début de
quinquennat pas en fin de quinquennat et
surtout parce que emmanuel macron fait
ce pour quoi il a été élu par ses
électeurs
quand françois hollande donné le
sentiment en fin de course de faire
exactement contre-pied de ce pourquoi il
avait choisi alors justement on a des
gars des images de la fin de la
manifestation dit marc guillaume point
du figaro.fr
avec quelques heures à paris comme il y
en a eu à nantes dans l'après midi
finalement toute cette affaire ça montre
que la france est réformable
contrairement à ce qu'on a longtemps dit
il serait paradoxal que la france soit
pas alors que les français passent leur
temps à enghien il faut changer le petit
petit bémol parce que je pense que la
bataille pas complètement fini avec un
petit enjeu même si ça n'a pas été un
succès aujourd'hui le je pense que la
mobilisation des jeunes et enfin la
capacité des jeunes de se mobiliser
passe pas forcément sur les rails là bas
sur la voie travail mais sur la question
de la sélection américaine
c'est sur le quai de la question de la
sélection de l'université peu dans les
semaines qui viennent
être un déclencheur je dis pas qu'elle
le sera alors que déjà ça fait un mois
que
ils distribuent des tracts à la sq on
mobilise pas les étudiants comme ça en
trois semaines
arriver à faire croire aux étudiants
qu'on instaure la sélection entre
l'université ce qui est une blague on
instaure pas la sélection à l'entrée de
l'université on instaure une orientation
mais pas la sélection et c'est pas un
jeu de mots c'est pas du tout la même
chose
deuxièmement l'unef va beaucoup plus mal
qu'elle n'a jamais été
et dans un état de division considérable
est si considérable que cela déconsidère
et donc si vous mettez tous ces facteurs
en jambes troisièmement les jeunes il
partage aussi avec des banques
françaises qui a dit emmanuel rivière il
ya un clip qui fait pourquoi vous avez
un sondage on voit que l'héritière genre
et herman sont aux deux tiers pour la
sélection et est en plus arrivée du
temps qu'il ya même pas de sélection
donc les jeunes et enfin on changeait
alors il ya les syndicats étudiants et
notamment l'unef qui essaient de monter
ménez mais il faut reconnaître que ça
prend pas moi ça prend pas aujourd'hui
elle même pas un seul 10 est bloqué donc
moi je ne crois pas du tout à ce sénat à
ce scénario là pour moi les blocages
reviendront plus côté des jeunes
la difficulté qu'on parle de france
réformable ou pas on sent que la france
notamment du privé est réformable
mais ça fait un moment qu'on voit qu'il
ya plus de syndicats dans le privé va le
taux de syndication du privé est là où
ça va être beaucoup plus dur
on le sait parce que l'ail et qui sait
la fonction publique dès qu'on s'attache
s'attaque à la fonction publique à ses
privilèges de ses avantages en fonte
statut laon ça résiste parce que là il
ya les gros bataillons de la sncf d'edf
de des fonctionnaires qui descendent
vraiment dans la rue surtout si quaife
traversy par exemple prenons l'exemple
des régimes spéciaux de la sncf
si on change le régime spécial mais que
pour l'avenir
à mon avis la dans l'état de la france
et est même à la sncf ça peut passer
mais si on le change avec application
par exemple pour tous ceux qui ont moins
de 45 ans ou qui ont moins tant d'années
de la sa chambre mais il ya un élément
qui explique m la france est peu les
français sont moins mobilisables qui
l'ont été dans le passé c'est que ce
pays ne croit plus au progrès social
les électeurs de gauche ce pays
construit tout leur identité politique
autour de la conquête de nouveaux droits
à l'accompagnement désespère de cela
peut-être mais il ne croit plus vraiment
mon progresse aussi aller ça c'est très
démobilisateur on a par exemple sandrine
qui nous dit ne pensez vous pas que les
grèves ont tué les grèves n'y at il pas
d'autres moyens
plus efficace aujourd'hui pour faire
entendre votre voix ce que vous allez en
deux roues ce que voulait dire sur les
étudiants c'est que je ne dis pas que ça
se produira jeudi que les les éléments
déclencheur d'un mouvement étudiant les
ingrédients sont là non je dis pas
qu'ils sont là je dis qu'ils ne
répondent pas toujours une logique
rationnelle et qu'un mouvement étudiant
peut partir sur des choses totalement
annexes et cessez le feu
la petite chose dont je me méfierais si
j'étais amené demain quand vous avez
tellement raison que sur la
prévisibilité que si on veut faire le
bon choix il faut prévoir une explosion
étudiante parce que si elle n'a pas lieu
tout le monde oubliera votre prévision
et c'est à l'avion doit vous étiez un
génie que vous l'avez vu venir ce
collier les mouvement social sont une
alchimie qui est extrêmement difficile
merci les mouvements sociaux sociaux
sont une alchimie extrêmement difficile
à anticiper et à prévoir fin mai mais si
le modéliser sa large audience et après
ça relève pas exactement du mouvement
social au sens de monsieur classique
avec deux syndicats c'est d'ailleurs
c'est qu'on le sait il ya quand même ce
cd petit groupe d'agitateurs et
notamment c'est souvent plus les lycées
d'ailleurs si on n'intervient puisque on
leur dit
emballement s'intéresser un peu
l'attention je suis sûr que si vous le
faites avec voulait répéter sociaux ne
distribue pas les bons et les mauvais
points et on va écouter pierre laurent
secrétaire national du parti communiste
qui rappelle quand même que
effectivement dans les sondages 65% des
français s'estiment perdants pour le
moment je crois que les gens ont compris
une chose c'est que emmanuel macron
c'est le père noël des riches et un
sondage récent je crois il ya deux jours
a dit que 65 % des gens pensaient qu'ils
allaient être les perdantes cette
politique est malheureusement ils ont
raison donc il faut stopper cette
politique il ya beaucoup de gens qui le
comprennent et la mobilisation se
construit je ne dis pas que c'est facile
mais se construit et je complète avec la
question du jour du figaro qui était ce
que la loi travail va créer des emplois
et 59 % de nos internautes alexis
dizaine ont donc vivement une réaction
de maillard hier soir on est dans un
climat de scepticisme il faut quand même
pas oublier que voilà j'ai tout à
l'heure que nous a regardés l'extérieur
avec un grand soulagement quand emmanuel
macron est élu le pays qui a élu
emmanuel macron avec 24% au premier tour
est un pays très énervé dubitatif quel
sentiment de sept trophées avoir dans le
passé pour distribuer des bons de
confiance à tout va en ce moment puis
par ailleurs sur la question du chômage
ça a été tellement annoncée pour mi
que les français du peine à y croire ils
mettront des mois si le chômage baissait
avant de considérer que oui
effectivement le chômage baisse et puis
voilà je crois être un peu au delà de la
wattine ma carrière de sondeurs je ne
verrai jamais un sondage où la majorité
des gens mais ils diront je vous
conseille je considère je suis gagnant
de la politique mise en oeuvre et ce
qu'on peut ajouter un mot je pense que
il est des gens qui peuvent dire qu'ils
pensent qu'ils seront perdants qui est
néanmoins crise après c'est très
important de mettre ceux des moches
moi je peux vous dire par exemple
beaucoup d'autres gens vont raconter à
bombay dix bombes façon il faut et
pendant ce temps là emmanuel macron
accélère avec ilan c'est un peu ce côté
on avait dit un peu carpet bombing pour
sarkozy en le une réforme est à peine
passé qu il en présente trois autres
c'est ça sarkozy à un moment il a essayé
de tout faire en même temps là je dirais
que macro et semble aller moins vite au
début mais après du coup l'enchaînement
et plus et plusieurs séquences et
puisqu'on on dit bon bah ça y est
maintenant il ya eu le droit du travail
et va y avoir la formation et
l'apprentissage
et puis derrière il ya les retraites qui
commence à se profiler il ya rien
université qui est un peu entre qui est
venu un peu perturbé ça et d'ailleurs on
a vu l'inquiétude quand même du
gouvernement sur cette affaire
d'université parce que ce que vous
disiez à l'instant sur le risque
d'explosion sent que là dessus le
gouvernement il est très présent et
perturber le bel ordonnancement là il
fallait faire mais c'est vrai que par
rapport à cette espèce d'enchaînements
assez mécanique est bien calibré il ce
truc là est arrivé et là on n'a sorti
qu'un peu comme un fouet et malgré tout
en léger recul par rapport aux
intentions initialement affichées
quitter sinon une sélection absolument
affiché mais enfin à peu près
revendiquer sa volonté d' embrouille et
la faire pour surtout ne peut que l'on
ne puisse pas dire aux étudiants qui a
une sélection mais à ceux cet événement
près après c'est vrai que pour l'instant
les choses s'enchaînent plutôt bien
formation apprentissage
ça devrait à mon avis pas posé
d'immenses problèmes politiques
allocations c'est avec le financement
des syndicats
oui mais ça reste des histoires de
boutique ce n'est pas là-dessus comme
c'est pas la typique on mobilise les
gens les syndicats pourraient très
énervé mais si les gens sont pas énervés
les mobiliseront pas et leurs derrières
ensuite
la question du chômage là c'est plus il
ya l'aspect qui embête les syndicats si
on va vous reprendre la gestion de ce
bon mais ça appareils les gens s'en
fichent totalement
en revanche la question de la
dégressivité des allocations chômage où
on va être plus dur pour que les gens
reprennent un emploi sinon la sas ça
peut ça peut ça peut être plus complet
sur la question après kate a longtemps
présenté comme l'obstacle majeur pour
les gouvernements qui voulaient réformer
traite les expériences de 2010 et 2013
ont montré que ce n'était plus tellement
le cas sauf que j'aime sociaux oui sauf
les régimes spéciaux pour eux mêmes
parce que en fait beaucoup de français
ont intégré mais je crois aussi les
salariés une partie de sa virgin
spéciaux ou intégré l'idée que de toute
façon la retraite c'était quelque chose
d'assez mouvance est frappant de voir
dans les études que l'on fait le nombre
de gens qui ne lisent la retraite si on
l'a la retraite pouf
si c'est oui enfin je sais pas à quelle
sauce je serai mangée à partir du monde
commence à y réfléchir
donc il n'ya plus le caractère butoir
que ce sujet avait en revanche
effectivement la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
la nièvre assure olivier duhamel à un
pronostic se prétend sociale ou pas bah
je mets le bémol la retraite sur les
régimes spéciaux en faisant un parallèle
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure si
on touche au régime spécial de retraite
de gens qui sont en poste à la sncf
les gens qui vont dire moi je suis
rentré avec ce contrat est dans le
contrat ge largage et que le droit est
donc c'est ça ce qu'on m'a dit donc on
doit faire ce qu'on m'a dit tout à
l'heure où on a dit les français
supportent beaucoup ce que macron fait
ce qu'il a dit juste avant qui ferait
bel argument il peut se retourner par le
cheminot et ben moi fait avec moi si
vous vous avez dit à fait entre nous et
ça ça l'allemand qui portent sa voix qui
porte sur la formation professionnelle
je trouve qu'il ya un petit paradoxe et
je pense que ce moment là sera sera à
mon avis important parce que évidemment
vous aviez raison c'est pas sur la
formation professionnelle que les
syndicats ou les roulés france à 108,20
mobilisés il n'y aura pas de monde dans
la rue sur la question de la formation
professionnelle donc on pourrait se dire
que il n'y a pas d'enjeu politique alors
que al'inverse je pense que cette
réforme là est déterminant politiquement
parce que c'est quelque chose que nombre
de gouvernements incalculable ont essayé
de réformer et n'y sont jamais arrivés
donc ça sera
soeur intéressant sur la capacité de
macron de faire ce qu'il a dit et de et
de vouloir débloquer la france et cette
question là elle de ce point de vue là
elle est intéressante elle sera
intéressante aussi sur les impacts sur
l'emploi et la capacité de 2 d'avoir un
système de formation qui permettent
d'amener des gens à l'emploi sur des
postes qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
être pourvus donc ce dock samangan
d'orford
on change de sujet on se projette au
moyen orient avec que donc saad hariri
le premier ministre libanais des
missionnaires qui devrait arriver samedi
à paris il est libre de ses mouvements a
sur les saoudiens alors qu'il se trouve
à ryadh des conditions un peu obscures
depuis le 4 novembre
alors ce vrai faux exil est il un succès
diplomatique pour emmanuel macron ou au
contraire est-ce dangereux de se mêler
de la politique entre l'iran l'arabie
saoudite par liban interposés on écoute
la version d' emmanuel macron et on en
reparle nous avons besoin d'un liban
fort d'une intégrité territoriale au
liban et nous avons besoin d'avoir des
dirigeants qu'ils soient justement
libres de leur choix de les exprimer
je me suis entretenu avec le prince
héritier mohammed bin salman et avec le
premier ministre saad hariri et nous
sommes convenus que je l'invité pour
quelques jours en france avec sa famille
c'est aussi un geste d'amitié et une
volonté marquée de la france de
contribuer au retour au calme et à la
stabilité au liban
il marque un point que c'est risqué si
l'arrivée revient à voter qui reviennent
mais s'il revient c'est indéniable en un
point qu'il marque c'est à dire que dia
hariri qui est retenu en vérité en otage
en résidence surveillée totalement libre
de ses non moins qu'on puisse dire
enfin quand on a vu son intervention il
était là on avait enlevé sa montre il
adhère totalement comme le nom et donc
le fait si un maquereau obtient ça c'est
une victoire de biotech ça veut pas dire
que ça réglera le problème du liban
enfin bon tout ça est extrêmement
compliqué mais en termes d'affirmations
diplomatique ça veut dire que il ya une
une intermédiation à une pression qui a
joué la question qu'on peut se poser
j'avoue que je ne sais pas pourquoi pas
chez moi je n'ai pas la réponse c'est
pourquoi les saoudiens qui sont pas du
jeu
à donner des points à dowjones ce point
un mac revient sûrement qu'il ya
sûrement une raison mais on peut
l'imaginer ça veut dire dit enfin
l'attitude classique de son régime c'est
de dire ce que vous dites ne nous
intéresse pas puis si vraiment il ya des
pressions
huit jours après qu'elle soit près de
nous décidons nous de remettre monsieur
ries non mais là ils ont fait ce choix
là je ne sais pas pourquoi il ya
sûrement quelque chose qu'on connaît pas
mais c'est intéressant
marc emmanuel bah quand alexis brézet
fait preuve d'une bonne foi exemple est
aussi exemplaire que rare et qu' il est
de répondre alexis et qui dit qu
incontestablement emmanuel macron marque
un point enfin va le marquer si mais
aussi va se réaliser
qu'est ce que vous voulez j'ajoute oui
bravo et manoeuvres des deux côtés mais
noël
bravo les deux oui il matin points
marque un point d'abord parce que ça
quand même contribué à 20.7 baisser la
pression un petit peu
au liban et pas simplement au liban
entre l'arabie saoudite et l'iran parce
qu'en fait le vrai enjeu qui a derrière
cette affaire c'est cette question là
c'est la question entre les entre le
japon comme sur cette histoire il ya
quand même deux niveaux il ya ce qu'on
nous dit c'est l'arabie saoudite contre
l'iran parce que hariri était trop
copains du hezbollah et c'est au liban
bon n'empêche que ça tombe exactement au
moment où le prince héritier arrête la
moitié de la famille royale les mets
dans le même hôtel car il y est en
résidence surveillée au même moment
qariri hariri qui lui a été très lié à
une partie de cette famille et tous et
tous moments la saison des affaires
ensemble
donc j'ai quand même le sentiment qu'à
ni que le prince hériter là un projet
global et qu'on peut pas séparer la
ferrari de la sphère des membres de la
famille qui ont été mis hors jeu
je sais pas je connais je sais pas mais
tout ça me paraît le fait que ça arrive
en même temps ça peut pas du hasard si
vous disiez tout à l'heure que va faire
du rugby il ya de l'argent derrière mais
évidemment c'est des sommes colossales a
pris sa vie apparemment ruinés mais où
est passé l'argent qui quoique alors on
a pour savoir comment quel état d'esprit
es saâda rit on peut dire son tweet je
ne sais pas c'est plus récent mais il
date de 10 hier et on va l'affiché à
l'écran il dit je veux répéter assuré
que je vais traite bien très très bien
je vais revenir si dieu le veut à mon
cher liban comme je voulais promis vous
verrez la question du jour composent
aujourd'hui alexis dans le figaro sur la
france at elle raison d'accueillir saad
hariri et ben guiga 69% de moi en tout
cas c'est elle que c'est sur 22 min 21
de oui c'est une on a raison mais on met
quand même les pieds dans un possible
bourbier
oui mais la france a toujours joué un
rôle particulier au liban donc
heureusement que la france est capable
de mener ce type d'action sur la scène
internationale on se plaint suffisamment
pour dire que voilà que on est un nain
diplomatique face aux états unis à la
russie à la chine et à la elle peut
avoir un rôle parce qu'on a on a une
présence historique sur place qui fait
qu on est un interlocuteur
voilà c'est bien de jouer ce rôle là
quand on peut parce que c'est ce qui
motive d'ailleurs les réponses de ceux
qui sont exprimés dans ce sens là sur le
site du figaro c'est cette ce retour
d'une certaine grandeur d'une importance
diplomatique de la france faisait partie
des griefs très lourd à l'encontre de
françois hollande qui font partie des
motifs de satisfaction passé sur la
sonata voilà et là c'est vrai que sur la
scène internationale ont-ils un crédit à
emmanuel macron de faire ce qu'il faut
et d'avoir restauré cela ce qui ne
compense pas tout à fait tous les griefs
et reproche aux interrogations qu'on
peut avoir moi ce qui m'a frappé sont
totalement meilleur de mon éventuel
domaine de compétence c'est que je pense
que vous avez bien résumé les et de
sujets est ce que on a raison parce que
c'est un acte diplomatique fort qui
replace la france aux jeux dans le jeu
ou est ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'importer les ennuis de ce qu'il faut
bien appeler quand même un univers très
compliqué et dangereux qu'est le
moyen-orient aujourd'hui j'ai eu
l'impression d'entendre à emmanuel
macron qu'il se posait il se posait
cette même question moment il répondait
à ses normes alternatif quelque chose
qui peut être cumulative bien sûr on
dira qu'on peut avoir raison de le faire
et combien et emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure on l'a souvent vu et mêlera
macron répondent comme ça au débotté
face à des caméras quand il est sûr de
lui convaincu il n'a pas du tout la
posture qu'il avait là pour ce qu'il se
pose aussi la question de savoir comment
la est là qu en ce moment les deux
ingrédients aux combinés guinée benjamin
qui nous dit effectivement fin qu'il
nous demande cet accueil en france
peut-il être bénéfique pour la france
sur la scène internationale
une question qui revient c'est
oui le drian là-dedans bon là il est en
ce moment mais lorient non le jean yves
le drian
comment on s'est fait bouffer tout cet
or 6 et 7 du premier degré on s'est
beaucoup moqué du parce que c'est vrai
que c'est très impressionnant convoi que
macron et
avec trump ya macron avec poutinien
makwaia jamais le drian limited affaires
étrangères on le voit jamais donc une
note
enfin l'or en l'occurrence c'est quand
même lui qui est allé sur place après
macron c'est vrai à ryad mais
semble-t-il le deal se fait au moment où
le drian est là donc on peut en déduire
qu'il a sans doute eu un oui je pense
que le deal c'est quand même plutôt fait
un moment où macron s'est arrêté à
l'aéroport de l'arabie saoudite et qu'il
a discuté pendant trois heures
l'aéroport avec le prince johnson
c'est le seul socialiste
alexis est bien donc il met un petit peu
de baume au coeur
y'avait pas qui avoue parce que ça vous
plairait pas alors on change de sujet
avec cette vente record de 450 millions
de dollars d'un tableau de léonard de
vinci 450 millions de dollars pour le
sauveur du monde c'est le nom du tableau
il a été vendu aux enchères hier à
londres ça n'a peut-être rien à voir
mais les transferts dans le foot les 220
millions d'euros pour neymar au psg la
spéculation sur les bitcoins à pourrait
un jour exploser
on va juste écouter de nouveau pierre
laurent pierre laurent qui était ce
matin sur france info et qui nous dit
c'est pas de l'amour de l'art c'est un
marché qui est devenu un marché
spéculatif de placement aussi tout le
monde le sait donc quand on atteint de
telles sommes
on n'est pas seulement dans l'amour de
l'art mais on est aussi dans le
placement d'argent pour souvent essayé
de faire échapper cet argent c'est un
commentaire sur cette vente record
annonce de l' amour dollars
dollars dollars et oui de la rampe a
pourtant qu'on soit dans une espèce de
bulle autour d'eux
le marché de l'art se pense que
l'histoire du tableau de vinci est un
peu une exception même si on est avait
atteint des chiffres faramineux dans des
ventes précédentes de plusieurs
centaines de millions de dollars
mais je pense qu'il ya quoi il ya quatre
cinq personnes au monde qui peuvent
aujourd'hui mettre une somme pareille
sur un tableau et que la spéculation sur
le tableau de vinci elle elle n'aura pas
lieu puisque c'est pas dans dans quinze
jours un mois
ou même un an que le tableau sera
revendue vous connaissez les corps leur
convenait pas à l'acquéreur non le temps
parler du qatar mais on n'en sait rien
le dernier en lice avant enfin l'avant
dernier était un chinois c'est bien mais
évidemment qu'elles semblent sont
faramineuses mais cet événement d'hier
n'est pas n'est pas le synonyme d'une
bulle qui pourrait causer je ne crois
pas c'est vrai que c'est un tableau et
c'est pas un a pas 36 sur le marché
comme et en même temps il avait atteint
en 60 ans il avait été vendu 50 livres
sterling d'ailleurs trois fois rien donc
il quand même un peu de spéculation
depuis la la le vendeur c'était le
patron de l'aef monaco le russe vient
pas de spéculation quand même oui là
mais bien sûr que c'est un univers un
petit peu spéculatif mais et mais il est
plus à mon avis sur les tableaux autour
de 200 millions de dollars
les picasso des matisse et c'est que sur
le sur le vin si les avocats de
placement ça fait quand même un euro
c'est moi que c'est comme ça là où il
faut commencer à dire ce qu'est une
bulle secor leur valeur augmente de
façon exponentielle beaucoup plus rapide
que la valeur du reste des choses et
c'est vrai qu'elles sont d'économistes
moi je n'en sais rien disent
qu'aujourd'hui a tellement de liquidités
sur la planète parce que les banques
centrales américaine européenne ont
commencé à faire tourner les machines à
sous que ses liquidités ne trouve pas se
placer dans des activités économiques
qui produisent suffisamment de bénéfices
pour que ces placements sont rentables
que du coup un certain nombre de sommes
d'argent cherchant désespérément à se
placer vont se placer dans des trucs un
peu irrationnel
comme l'art le foot le matin parce que
ce qui est trop il ya trop d'argent sur
la planète et que ça ça peut faire
craindre 10 et économistes un crack en
étant à peu près aussi incompétent sur
le marché de l'arc sur le marché du foot
suis sûr mais il me semble quand même
qu'il ya une vraie différence c'est à
dire qu'un joueur comme limare il
rapporte immédiatement en droits de
retransmission en produits dérivés etc
alors que la priori le christ rédempteur
c'est moi en tout cas à court terme
c'est moins évident même ajouté que plus
il est acheté cher le joueur de foot +
qui rapporte immédiatement monde parce
que le fait qu'il ait été acheté une
somme phénoménale fait qu'on achète
encore plus vite ces gilets ses trucs et
des machins campagnes marketing à 200
millions d'euros c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup d'autres types de cancers alors
valentin fils at nous a rejoint
valentin c'est pas vous l'acheteur
mystère ce n'est pas moi on se posait la
question mais non ce n'est pas moi
en revanche ce que je sais c'est que
grâce à notre partenaire visible règne
habituellement c'est une centaine
d'internautes qui twitte sur léonard de
vinci à ce sujet par contre depuis ce
matin je vous garantis ce sont des
vagues de tweets qui déferle par
milliers j'ai donc demandé à nos à nos
abonnés sur twitter ce qu'il pense du
prix de vente
un tel montant pour une oeuvre cela
relève de l'indécence
mais on ne vit pas dans le même monde
c'est une réponse récurrentes sur
twitter aujourd'hui et c'est celle de
léo je n'ai rien contre l'art au
contraire cependant tout cet argent
aurait pu arranger la vie de plusieurs
millions de personnes voire sauver des
pays entiers estime pour sa part flavie
même son de cloche chez les internautes
du figaro alors que des millions de
personnes meurent de faim de maladie
crève de tout mot avec une indifférence
totale
une seule personne achète un tableau de
plus de 400 millions de dollars
michel trouve que ce tableau ne devrait
pas atteindre cette somme de 450
millions de dollars
qu'en pensent ceux qui bataillent
journellement pour se nourrir se vêtir
et se loger d'autant plus dit il que
l'on ne sait que l'on n'est pas sûr que
l'auteur soit ce léonard à combien de
personnes vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté on aurait pu rendre le sourire
avec une telle somme demande
sept internautes du figaro enfin on
rappelle que ce tableau appartenait au
président de l'as monaco ce qui est ce
qui inspira pas de show ce commentaire
sur twitter
le mercato d'hiver s'annonce lourd du
côté de la principauté
effectivement oui je précise qu' il
n'est pas totalement authentifier ce
tableau d'une polémique alors maintenant
oui on se demande mais il ya toute une
histoire notamment sur la boule qui
représente le monde que tient le christ
et qui serait pas de la main de maître
les sans voix d'europe oui et puis
surtout elle elle reflète pas l est pas
bien peintes entre 10 mekouar lfa comme
une sphère normal le louvre d'abu dhabi
ça vous inspire
ça fait partie de ce ces petits indices
cumulé lui donne un rayonnement de la
france et ça fait partie aussi de ce
sentiment que voilà le centre de gravité
du monde est en train de plus et que
l'endroit où il ya de l'argent
maintenant c'est le moyen-orient et
beaucoup d'argent donc ça suscite des
sentiments ce probablement ambivalent
chez les gens qui sont contents que ce
soit le louvre abou dhabi et et non pas
un autre musée référente qu'ils soient
exportés
et puis voilà c'est l'idée que tout se
passe maintenant au moyen-orient qui se
trouve être à la fois la rencontre entre
les la plus grande confidentialité et
les plus grandes tensions et la plus
grande accumulation de l'argent c'est
une autre regard une autre époque dans
laquelle les gens sont amenés à se
projeter regarde mandat france oui
puisse pas seulement les oeuvres qui
vont pas seulement le nom le louvre
c'est aussi une extraordinaire
architecture pas un architecte français
jean nouvel
pas moi je suis de ceux qui trouvent ce
que j'ai vu je suis malheureusement je
ne suis pas allé mais alexis a dit qu'il
enverrait bientôt au logement qu'ils
n'enverraient bientôt mais c'est
magnifique c'est d'une beauté faut
laisser français donc ça aussi ça donne
une fierté je pense qu'il fallait encore
faut dire les choses
macro n'y est pour rien c'est chirac qui
avait lancé la donne qui était ministre
de la culture et le loup le monde
nouveau moi je le veux pendant les
travaux et c'est vrai que cette coupole
c'est absolument sublime et semoule ou
faux a peut être un peu trompeur ce que
j'en suis dit c'est les oeuvres du
louvre qui vont là bas c'est vrai dans
un premier temps c'est qu'on prenne à
10h30 mais l'excusé comment une parole
de louer palais d'autres musées mais
l'essentiel petit big c le bouddha bit
qui se constituent des collections avec
leurs fonds colossaux qu'ils achètent
sur le marché avec comme experts les
experts du louvre qui disent basta ça
vaut ça ça vaut pas ça veut pas donc
c'est c'est pas les collections du
louvre qu'on va seul combat qu'on voit
installé là bas mais c'est vrai que pour
le rayonnement de la france c'est quand
même une belle c'est une très belle
opération
proches et simples de la rapporte de
l'argent par ailleurs parce que tout ça
évidemment ça rapporte beaucoup d'argent
on l'ouvré à l'époque les conservateurs
du louvre etc étaient un peu réticents
parce qu'ils aient on va nous piquer nos
oeuvres est bon ils se sont rendu compte
que ça permet tait au louvre de financer
d'autres acquisitions et c'est plus
joyeux de voir baisser venir financer
des oeuvres d'art que des dieux grecs
bon je vous propose une prochaine
édition deux points de vue
abou dhabi 3 musées ses consignes et
merci beaucoup et ne nous quitte et pas
figaro live un focus alors qui allie la
mode le sport je ne sais pas très bien
mais c'est vincent roux qui va vous le
présenter merci à bientôt pour une
prochaine édition
[Musique]